donnez la ferrière bonsoir et bienvenue
à 24,60 un plaisir de vous parler pour
avoir un peu votre réaction cette
tempête politique
quand la politique se mêle de
littérature quelle est votre réaction
devant ça or précisément c'est étonnant
ça m'a poussé littéralement à aller dans
la bibliothèque pour chercher les les
trois magnifiques volume et de minuit
parce qu'il ya tout vu un contexte et
c'est ça que la littérature existe elle
existe depuis très longtemps
elle peut aider à comprendre les hommes
leur mouvement la société les manières
ce qui se trame derrière les choses
aussi et qui des fois les gens qui sont
les acteurs et ne comprennent pas
toujours
par exemple on parle de deux plaques
fils de brasles fait si on parle qui
kiffe ce qui est plutôt qu'il ya un lien
avec la culture américaine là disons la
politique américaine l'histoire même des
noirs et des blancs aux états unis et de
l' esclavage mais aladin c'est quelque
chose de différent à l'ademe sur le
faire par un être vivant c'est un
personnage littéraire qui vient des
mille et une nuits et ccc c'est un set
un trajet assez difficile halladay est
un conte convient de perth et
actuellement nous savons très bien que
l'iran c'est à dire la perse est presque
une situation complexe et compliquée
avec les états unis
et voilà que pour nous au canada là la
perse et arrive dans une histoire
absolument de mille et une nuits ce qui
veut dire que le canada est quand même
un pays assez à ces pacifistes
nous sommes dans la littérature tandis
que les états unis sont peut-être est
pas loin d'être dans la guerre mais
justin trudeau aujourd'hui s'excuse dix
fois plus tôt que dans un sens grave je
n'aurais pas dû faire cela je ne savais
pas que je que je blessé je ne
connaissais pas la réalité de ces gens
qui sont victimes de discrimination au
fond ce que vous nous dites c'est que se
déguiser en
en noir comme soi pour éviter
d'affronter ou encore aladin ce n'est
pas un blackface non ce n'est pas du
tout un black fils avait un black fait
s'il faudra qu'il y ait enfin un goût
certain et de vouloir ridiculiser
déshumanisé et l'autre et dans le cas de
la première image que j'ai vu où il
était accompagné de jeunes femmes
magnifiques
il avait un très beau turban et les
femmes ne semblait pas effrayé de sa
présence quand il y avait black fait aux
états unis.le l'envi de ridiculiser on
mettait des noix avec un regard effrayé
de grosses lèvres des yeux un peu
entouré de moeurs qui donne un côté à la
fois effrayée effrayant et il n'y avait
pas du tout cet aspect de séduction et
qu'on a vu dans donc dans la photo c'est
étrange parce que encore quand elle noie
met du blanc sur le visage parce que ça
arrive aussi
et pour pour injure pour quoi que ce
soit on dit que c'est un colonisé et qu'
il voudrait bien devenir blanc et il ne
sait comment faire alors que quand un
blanc amandinois c'est le visage et on
dit qu'il est raciste c'est à dire le
noir ne peut être que quelque chose
qu'on rejette et peut-être que parfois
c'est parce qu'on voulait être noir
ouais parfois il peut avoir un fantasme
le fantasme de vouloir quelqu'un d'autre
mais en même temps quand même monsieur
trudeau fait cet acte de contrition fait
ses excuses et qu'on le traite de
raciste d'une part et d'autre part les
gens disent ou tempête dans un verre
d'eau
il n'avait pas l'intention de
ridiculiser nez de dénigrer vous accepté
les excuses de monsieur trudeau il
excuse je n'ai pas accepté les excuses
de monsieur trudeau les excuses de
monsieur trudeau n'ont rien à voir avec
cette histoire c'est tout simplement la
politique et c'est l'amérique du nord
nous nous disons société laïque mais en
fait nous sommes toujours dans la
confession publique
c'est le petit catéchisme qui est là
s'il ne s'excuse pas il n'avancera pas
il ne pourra pas dire un mot de sa de sa
campagne
de celles de ses projets et politiques
il le sait et il va s'excuser jusqu'à ce
qu'il craque au guide tombe en larmes ou
qu'ils disent
bon peut-être que je pense à me retirer
et là tout le monde avait donné une tape
dans le dos en disant on blaguait ce
n'était pas si important que cela
et ça je l'écris dans tout ce qu'on ne
te dirai pas mungo et cette idée de
confession dans une société qui se dit
et pourtant de plus en plus laïque et
c'est étonnant parce qu'elle n'a rien à
voir avec avec l'histoire
on est dans un autre dynamique on est
désolé mais quand il est libéré
belafonte et il est dans l'admiration
d'une certaine manière il n'est pas
absolument il voudrait talibés
l'affronter et annie bel affronter est
aussi noir et donc il a quand on veut
être quelqu'un d'autre quand on veut
limiter on va jusqu'à je pense pas qu'il
y a il dit il y a chez les noirs des
noix qui voudrait être blanc parce qu'il
y à un blanc qu'ils admirent moi
j'admire aussi luis borgès l'écrivain et
argentins et il ya beaucoup de blancs
aussi de blanc qui voulait être noir et
qui voit une santé ce 10ème et qui
pousse l'admiration à devenir l'autre on
n'est pas du tout dans ce cas c'est même
une insulte et à cela au black fils et
aux histoires du racisme ce qui est
étonnant dans cette affaire c'est que
les noirs beaucoup de noirs dit ce qu'
il n'y a pas de racistes mais là on
dirait qu'on n'a pas des potentialités
ça les idées noires au québec a dit
qu'il n'y avait pas de racisme ici oui
la ligue des noirs du sommet mais on
n'écoute pas trop ça au mondial c'est
une affaire qui se passe entre
politiciens blanc et la faire se passe
sur un autre terrain clos c'est pour ça
que je dis ça n'a rien à voir avec cela
c'est la politique qui continue de plus
il faut dire que ça s'appelle et reggae
night les mille et une nuits ces arabes
on n'a pas demandé on n'a demandé aucun
arabe ce qu'il pense de cela alors que
cette histoire d'aladin j'ai aladin sais
c'est pas du tout une histoire
occidentale c'est une histoire arabe et
je le redis il ne s'agit pas d'un être
humain
sept personnages littéraires et quand je
vois un journaliste et
entré à toronto la photo où l'on voit
avec ces jeunes filles et le demandait
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
sans dire le contexte sans dieu qu'il
s'agit de personnages littéraires des
mille et une nuits qui a peut-être le
livre le plus adapté en spectacle
renseignements carnaval en fait grande
fête
en europe on déguisement au fessier
aucun aval de venise dans les fêtes de
venise dans les fêtes dans la grande
aristocratie française avec marseille
pousse les vilenies ont été adaptés
souvent et les gens se déguisent et
parce que il y à une pléiade de
personnages dans les mille et une nuits
mais qu'est ce que c'est la vraie mme
lacroix les vrais black rêve pour vous
qu'est ce que c'est qu'elle est abaissé
à l'idée de ridiculiser
c'est l'idée du millier cd l'idée de
montrer que ce ne sont pas des êtres
humains et nous savons très bien par
exemple venant d'europe le code le code
noir disait que le net est un bien
meuble c'est à dire ce n'est pas un être
humain c'est un bien meuble c'est un
animal c'est l'idée de de dio que vous
n'avez pas de présence humaine de
sensibilité d'émotions humaines vous ne
pouvez pas vous retrouver dans un salon
avec dès janvier alors que le personnage
d'aladin il est jeune fille qui était
dessous la photo où l'on monte n'avait
pas l'air d'être effrayé d'être devant
un monstre qui pourrait à tout moment
mettre le feu ou ou les tuer les
étrangler on n'avait pas de monstres et
dans cette photo il ya même une forme de
séduction et dans la photo et surtout il
faut savoir qu'ils en parlent
et ce ne sont pas des gens toujours
honnête sur la question du racisme
la question c'est qu'est ce qu'ils ont
fait pour le contre le racisme et ceux
qui sont ici ceux qui s'en empare et
c'est pas des gens qu'on qu'on voit
toujours sur le fond à à dénoncer le
racisme ils en ont contre un homme
politique qui est en campagne électorale
et actes il est accusé cette peau de
banane et
je suppose que quand on se sera pas lui
ce sera un autre pour qui on sentira un
petit scandale et ce sont les aléas et
d'une campagne électorale
et moi je n'interviens jamais dans les
affaires politiques
parce que je sais ce n'est jamais ce
qu'on pense qui se passe et mais j'ai
trouvé que c'était injuste c'est qu'on
faisait la queue des gens en pharisiens
hypocrites se cache derrière une chose
est pour pour dénoncer un autre quand
ils sont peut être eux mêmes aussi
affublé des mêmes défauts et si c'est un
défaut
quant au fait que monsieur trudeau
n'arrête pas de s'excuser je le dis ça
n'a rien à voir avec ce magnifique
mi-mandat mille et une nuits ni le
cheikh al adha mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est que radio canada peut
être autrefois faisait cela je ne sais
pas on croit toujours et on est toujours
nostalgique de ce qui s'est passé avant
mais il me semble c'est intéressant
d'aller demander à un psychologue
c'est une poche de quelqu'un qui
voudrait devenir à la baie à la dire
c'était un jeune homme turbulent et qui
avait de mauvaises fréquentations qui
vivait en chine avec son père et qui
était très pauvre et qui a approuvé
cette lampe parce qu'un magicien l'a mis
dans un trou et lui a dit et parce qu'il
voulait être ezzor est et deux bus
données trésorerie et la lampe lui il a
voulu garder la lampe qui lui donne
disons qu'il ne permet de faire des
miracles dont celui de se marier avec
une princesse c'est un conte de rêve
je vois très bien ce jeune homme est
ce jeune trudeau qui qui rêvent déposer
une princesse
et ce n'est pas du tout quelque chose de
mauvais et à la dépossède une lampe
merveilleuse
peut-être que ce jeune homme qui est
maintenant premier ministre et candidat
voudrait bien garder la langue qui lui
permettra de devenir premier ministre
mais une dernière question parce qu'on
forme monsieur trudeau a dit que vous
étiez vous avez vu que vous aviez déjà
qu'avec dans ces années là on dit
souvent qu ici peut-être au québec où on
a été moins touchée ou informés de ce
qu'était le black fait senso nous c'est
quelque chose qui nous échappe est
peut-être comme communauté non et que
peut-être il a dit qu'il ne savait pas
ce qu'il faisait à l'époque
oui mais toujours de la difficulté à
apprendre ce que monsieur trudeau dit au
coeur de la tempête
parce que tout ce qu'il veut c'est
s'excuser assez faire croire à son
honnêteté
jusqu'à ce qu'on lui pardonne mais ça je
ne suis pas d'ordre dans cette équipe a
une seconde qu'il s'agit de blattes fils
je ne crois pas une seconde que trudeau
a besoin de s'excuser a à ce point et je
ne crois pas une seconde que les gens
qui lui demande sans cesse de s'excuser
je parle des hommes politiques qui
l'entourent qui sont dans des parties
opposées enfin je ne crois pas dans leur
honnêteté dans cette histoire merci
beaucoup dany laferrière ou plaisir de
vous reparler mais surtout plaisir de
vous relire et lire merci merci merci et
maintenant c'est plutôt ça deux mille et
une nuits si au moins ça fait lire la
mieux une nuit ce serait une très bonne
chose
merci beaucoup beaucoup d'elle